the most dramatic sports stories of 1964
were played out over the long course of the
Congressional Country Club in Washington where
America's top golf pros contested the national
open Arnold Palmer bidding for the Grand Slam of
golf tees off on the grueling 36 hole final day
Ken Venturi who hasn't won a tournament in many
years starts off on a birdie binge by rolling the
ball up to the cup or number one then waiting
it out until it drops in for his first bird
this final day is expected to be a dogfight
between Arnie Palmer and Tommy Jacobs Jacobs
as the leader as he dumps in a 6-footer for
a par on the seventh near collapse from the
heat at the end of the first 18 venturi comes
back to finish the front nine in even par with
his beautiful birdie putt or not Arnie Palmer
has almost the same problem and doesn't make
it Venturi lead Jacobs by two strokes and Palmer
has been unable to gain ground on either of them
venturi plods toward the 72nd and final green
still in the lead but the crowd wonders if he
can make it ken is suffering from heat exhaustion
Venturi's ball is found to trap at the edge of the
18th but he pulls himself together in true
championship style to hit a beautiful shot
Venturi's left himself with a 15-foot putt
for his farm ken sends it home to finish in
style in one of the greatest comebacks of
this or any year venturi moves boldly out
of the shadows and into the sunlight to capture
the most coveted crown in golf the United States
Open US Open Golf Championship on the winged
foot course at Mamaroneck New York and early
downpour delays the start of the third round two
hours but the Sun is still shining on men hope
sam snead another crowd favorite makes a
strong bid for the 67 in the third round
but the steadiest putter in the field is
Bill Casper Augie dark horse
from Apple Valley California
Casper after a second round 68 that
put him in the lead shows no sign of
folding under pressure as he gives par
another one here he is on the 17th green
suddenly another Californian Bob Rosburg of Palo
Alto decides to cut himself in on the contention
Rosberg scores a 67 tying Sneed for the
best round of the tournament and moves
up among the leaders Lord Harmon the host
club Pro is also hanging on watch this one
but at the rounds end Casper is still
up there Casper three strokes ahead
but 18 votes to go another violent
storm strikes in the last round is
delayed until Sunday high winds sweep
the course as they start the stretch run
Hogan's starting at 211
three strokes behind Casper
as per the man in front
like sucuk 2:13 still a possibility
Rosberg very much in the picture and Snead
still seeking a one big title he hasn't won
gale winds add to the hazards Hogan and Snead
gradually dropped back as it develops into a
three-way struggle while Caspar fights
to hang on sooo check and Mossberg come
on with strong challenges here sooo check at
the next to last hole still chasing Casper
Rosberg needs a birdie to catch up
but this is as close as he can come
Gasper is still in command
as he comes to the final home
the snob pro from the golden slope finishes
with 282 to over par for the tournament just
enough to be bused forgot by one stroke it's a
$12,000 triumph Amil Casper and that's only the
beginning of what the title is worth to an Open
champion a happy day for the California couple